you knew this was coming pete trailer
breakdown reaction here
for eternals and all that was unveiled
we're gonna watch the one from heavy
spoilers today especially because i
wanted to plug that this week
uh john and i we're gonna be doing an
interview with paul from heavy spoilers
very excited to do it been coordinating
with him
it'll be like afternoon his time because
he's in the uk it'll be 9 a.m
our time so we'll be sprightly during it
sprite eternals side note
got an interview that i did uh solo with
three c films coming out later this week
so keep a lookout for that i'd say i'm
most excited for
gemma chan and cersei and brian tyree
henry as fastos i hope they make him go
so gay just like the jst the most
stereotypically flamboyant
defensive portrayal of the lgbt
character
coming to the embassy marvel did not get
this one right
welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul and it feels like we've
been waiting forever
for a look at the turtles uh not my best
joke yeah i'll admit
but new rock stars and screen crush has
been a while together videos yet
so you're stuck with me for now now in
this we're going to be breaking down
everything you need to know about the
new marvel movie the trailer itself
and certain leaks about the film's story
sure its director chloe zhao
has just won the oscar for bets director
and it's clear that this movie is gonna
be something different
if you love the video 3000 then please
click the thumbs up button
and don't forget to subscribe for
breakdowns like this each and every day
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into
our eternals trailer breakdown man can
you imagine how lucky marvel must feel
right now to
have chloe's shower in their corner yeah
it wasn't like
chloe won let's hire her it's like oh
she won
this just does better for us now we made
a good choice we paid attention to the
buzz
okay so this game attached to a video by
marvel that showed their past movies as
well as what was coming down the line
not only did it showcase some brand new
and unseen footage from black widow but
it also contains several new scenes from
shanghai
this included him using a knife against
death dealer in a moment that was very
reminiscent of bucky fighting against
captain america
they announced that black panther ii
will have the subtitle wakanda
will be out on july 8th 2022. there was
also an announcement of the marvels
coming november 11
2022 which i'm guessing stars captain
marvel
and miss marvel 900 on that though so if
you know different yeah
drop a comment below now before that's
confirmed and monica rambo
i feel like we need to talk about the
characters in the film and who the
eternals themselves are
up top you should know that the eternals
are well eternal in their lifespan
and this film itself is said to take
place both in present day
and thousands of years before the
infamous words
i am iron man so expect to see a lot of
prequel elements
as well as discussions of the celestials
who have been hinted at in films such as
guardians of the galaxy
in the movie we will apparently watch
the origins of the eternals
and how they ended up on earth which is
where they attempted to blend in with
society now according to leaks on the
movie we will open with a flashback to
the past in which we learned that the
celestials created the deviants in order
to hunt down predators
who posed a threat to newly evolving
life however the deviants grew a
bloodlust from doing this
and ended up stamping out life before it
could rise up
thanos himself is actually a deviant and
this idea of genocide being laced
throughout his ancestors ideology
does explain why he wanted to destroy
all life in the universe
instead of just doubling the resources
i'm hearing too
that there's rumors that you might see
thanos's brother maybe in the film
during or maybe a post-credits scene
setting him up i think a post-credit
scene would be better uh his brother's
star fox
he has another name but i know star fox
is one of them yeah
64. do a barrel roll and i actually
think the scrolls are also
they deviate from the deviants oh
all the deviants are coming out that
would make sense too because we got the
secret invasion coming up it'll all tie
together
now after realizing that they'd made a
monster the celestials decided to
counter this by creating the eternals
who would defend against their
destruction
throughout the galaxy up top is the
leader of the group icarus
played by richard madden he's basically
a superman
and along with being bulletproof he can
fly throw things really
far because he's super strong and he
also has the ability to fire cosmic
blasts from his eyes he'll you also know
that gemma chan is going to be playing a
big part in the film too
protagonist fighting who has the ability
to manipulate mata on a molecular level
though chan has already played minerva
and captain marvel
like michelle yo she's getting another
shot and will likely be sticking as this
character
going forward and that's because cersei
is actually in love with the black
knight
played by kit harrington if you know
nothing jon snow
about him he's basically your sword
wielding medieval knight type character
that will be using it to stab deviants
instead of danny
dane whitman's name and i think he i
don't think he'll become black
knight in this film uh i don't think he
will especially because of what kit
harrington has talked about we're not
being part of like the main cast
it'd be cool if like they set him up to
become black you're just with dane
whitman
in the movie here and then you go into
uh
like the next one or he's black knight
yeah it'd be cool
played by martin lawrence it'll be great
or maybe kitt harrington just knows
nothing and they've kept him in the dark
haha
and when it comes to cersei a lot of
people said like man she probably she
probably could have taken out thanos
herself she could turn him into a potato
if she wanted to or an elmo doll or a
furby
or a stapler next up is thina played by
angelina jolie
born in olympia during ancient greece
dina was picked by zeus to be the
representative of his daughter adinas
if you played any of the god of war
games or are well versed in greek
mythology
then you may recognize her name and it's
now be confirmed that russell crowe is
also playing the king of the gods
so expect some more call backs today's
myths and legends
dina has fought in several wars over the
centuries and is able to form
any weapon out of cosmic energy we see
her wielding one of these in the first
look
which appears to be a sword glowing with
the light next
up is commander who is playing kingo
whereas the rest of the group have kept
a low profile over the years
kingo has become a bollywood star so
that his other abilities get overlooked
in the trailer we can see a man standing
beside him with a camera documentary and
what looks to be a film set in the
background
oh get a lot of johnny cage vibes from
this
good car yeah absolutely i hear that he
actually does have like a bollywood
number i think he was on a podcast where
he talked about doing like a dance
routine like
50 professional dancers or something
like that yeah
that's cool you also have salma hayek as
ajak who is the healer of the group
and she can basically channel cosmic
energy in order to provide
extra added life force to anyone she
chooses to
adria can also telepathically
communicate with the celestials
and thus i think she will be used in
some form to reach out to them in the
movie
god damn that that picture i swear i
didn't pick it on purpose that's from
google that one now we see her in the
first show
like wow you know that the eternals
actually split up during their time
and ajax was a guy in the comics oh ha
ha
yeah that's good they updated that yeah
there's a real john rambo thing going on
here
that's good well we needed that presence
in this movie we needed a tough
burly also gorgeous presence well i
believe the next shot of them on the
beaches
they were unable to agree on a lot of
things and ended up going their separate
ways before coming together
which is likely the shot that follows on
from that you can catch cersei at a
similar location at one point
making me believe that she has come here
to talk things out with ajak
we also have ryan tyree henry as fastos
who is the inventor of the eternals
marvel have said that he's going to be
the first gay superhero in the mcu
and that he will be opening the door for
more inclusive characters to come into
the franchise
i love the way that's
we'll get some more gay characters i
didn't know you were gay
oh oh maybe a trend wow let's do it is
so progressive
over the millennia he has worked in the
shadows helping humanity to grow
technologically
and he's got his fingers in more things
than tony stark next up is lauren
ridloff as makari
who has superhuman speed and can be seen
showing this off in the trailer
makari is also deaf so it's going to be
interesting to see
how they handle this in the movie i
heard makaris also going to be deaf and
mute which is an interesting take
because i don't think makari in the
comics is actually
deaf i think makar is also a guy in the
comics but i don't think bakari is deaf
for mute in the comics
that'll be an interesting take but
mccarthy's like the scout of the group
donnelly is playing gilgamesh who's a
massive hulk of a man
that can surround himself in an
exoskeleton of cosmic energy
and there's also leah mchugh as sprite
sprite seems like a young child on the
surface
but she like the rest of the group is
thousands of years old
she's trapped in this form but wiser
than she looks and is capable of
projecting lifelike illusions
lastly out of the main cast of
characters is druid played by barry
cohen whose name i always butcher
so apologies and advance he's a psychic
that can manipulate the minds of others
and initially he looks like he's one of
the good guys that wants what's best for
humanity
however this leads to him controlling
them and taking away their free will
which is sort of similar to what scarlet
witch did in one division but i imagine
that druid is going to start off like a
little bit more with an obvious
sinister tone to the character he's
going to be the one who's
poised to turn because yeah he mainly i
think like he can
like heavily strongly like prey on
people's fears
specifically i don't know you could be
set up to be probably one of the
villains of the movie too
doesn't sound like a villainous
character to me just look at his photos
he looks exactly that drawing
look at those eyes it just looks so
inviting and warm in the trailer we
catch a shot of the group
out of village and in the background you
can see what looks like they just got
done singing
standing in a row looking at the
characters according to the leaks when
the group go to reunite
they visit a village that he has taken
over and here they find that he's mind
controlling everyone in order to stop oh
i have my theories that he's gonna end
up being the big bad in the movie but of
course
let me know if you disagree as it could
really go anyway
now as for the trailer itself you know
it's it's very short and sweet and i'm
going to be honest
and say that of everything on the face
for slate the eternals are probably the
people that i know least about
in general when it comes to the cosmic
side of marvel i just find the
overpowered superheroes slightly
uninteresting
there's a cameraman captain
in that shot of all the eternal i don't
know if it's maybe like
justified by command on johnny's
character but over his shoulder you can
see there's a guy with a camera
i think uh kingo is like doing like a
documentary or something too
oh okay yeah people on twitter were
going nuts people like can you see the
cameraman but yeah
now knowing especially more about like
seeing that other shot with the guy
following him with the camcorder like
yeah maybe this is just
he's got part of his career like it
seems like a weird thing to have
happen being that you know turtles are
you dealing yeah
like why would you break your camera but
at the same time you know i don't know
actually be funny if it is a mistake i
don't know i mean it could be the same
guy who we saw in the previous shot who
was next to him before you know
but that is a huge camera yeah that's a
good guy
well maybe that camera is super powered
and it cannot bulk up depending on the
needs of the shot
true and in the case of captain marvel i
just think they're almost too perfect to
fully relate to
marvel is great when it's doing
grounding characters that have been
blessed with incredible gifts
but at this point i also know that kevin
feige here we trust him
and i'm sure they can knock it out of
the park with whatever they touch
now though i've rattled off a lot of
negatives there i do think that they
have the opportunity to really flesh out
the history and law of the mcu here
which i think will be fascinating
however it also depends on how long they
stay in the past
and i actually hope we properly explore
it without it just being a prologue
so we can see things like the rise of
thanos so little that we know about the
history of the universe and the
celestials are fascinating creatures
that pretty much shape the galaxy to be
the way that it is
so lots of things to explore and i know
i've criticized them for perhaps being
too godly
i do think marvel will be able to give
these characters something that people
will find
some common ground with cersei in the
trailer says they're the ones who
changed everything
and this is clearly hinted with sadness
so they can provide an interesting
aspect and character study
hopefully i'm just a bit unfamiliar with
the best stories by them yeah
and because of this i'm unsure on how
things will be handled and so on
i don't know how they're going to
integrate into the universe and excuse
me for making
the the worst breakdown ever that being
said though yeah the film does look
interesting
we're not gonna see it the director is
also of course coming off the back of an
oscar win
so you can bet there are a lot of eyes
on this project the cast is also
incredible too
and arguably one of the best ensembles
that marvel have put together
so yeah i am excited for it yeah sorry
for being a negative nancy there
and it was a really great trailer really
oh yeah there's negative thoughts
you raised a concern and now you're the
negative guy online
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below share your thoughts
on the first look
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now so if that's you
then message me on twitter
heavyspoilers if you want something else
to watch then make sure you check out
our breakdown of invincible episode 8
which will be linked on screen right now
we went over the finale from top to
bottom and talked about all the things
you need to know
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you have any questions without the way
thank you for sending through the video
i've been paul i'll see you next time
take care peace
i mean you killed it on the invincible
breakdowns in terms of view count i
personally haven't seen any just because
i like that i know nothing about
invincible and i kind of want to just
keep it that way
moving forward with the rest of the
seasons but dude no i thought this was
great man
you're like weirdly apologetic in the
end feeling like you
i think that's a fair point so you get
these like godlike characters they live
forever
they seem impossible to kill you know
like they seem like wow
yeah exactly that is a concern too what
is the actual plot set up where the
stakes can be felt and i feel like
actually having
druid as your villain making it a
personal villain would be the best bet
to go about it
yeah absolutely um and that way he can
also uh manipulate their minds and stuff
like that so i thought there's a lot of
interesting things you can explore yeah
i don't think you were out of line there
anyway guys eternals are you guys
excited for it leave your thoughts down
below
subscribe to heavy spoilers if you
haven't done so already i'll probably
get that
uh interview out next week we haven't
even filmed it yet
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell hit that like button
last but not least
david gandy you are eternally
in my heart i just wanted to shout you
out because i miss your face i miss your
kind
presence your warm inviting
eyes that don't mind control me in any
nefarious ways other than to
just think of you every single day and
long
for your presence once again it's been
so long since we went out and had a
brunch
or something like that and you live even
further away all the time before
just that one couple of times we've had
we've had the one brunch right yes but
david gandy come out and visit again
it's it's the world's opening back up
people are getting
immunized it's time for us to see you
again
and to give you a high five and to just
reunite and feel the love man so that we
can internally be
together david i hope you're doing well
i hope your recovery is continuing on a
good path
and much love man just wanted to send
you some love
very well thanks
you